[Music]
good morning John it's Monday February
12 and I'm back in Montana can't you
tell actually I'm probably on a plane
right now on my way to Montana either
that or I'm in Montana trying to chip
through about three inches of ice that
have warmed up my sidewalk this is
pretty much the most beautiful day that
I'm gonna see for a long time so I
figured I'd make my video a little early
so you continue in Florida doing four
things and a Florida hat Florida kayak
in a Florida Intracoastal Waterway
surrounded by Florida birds I'm gonna
fish Meridian's
and me and Katherine
well it's official you're going to be
getting this video bought while I'm on a
plane I think it's this short leg the
one from Denver to Missoula and I'm in
Denver right now I am as you know a
little bit of an amateur naturalist and
I'm a huge fan of birds and also a huge
kind of taking pictures of birds so I
wanted to share with you some of the
birds that I saw and took pictures off
while on
of florida offspring black-crowned night
herons yellow crown night herons little
blue herons great blue herons
tri-colored Heron Snowy Egrets great
egrets cormorants and Hingis ibis
muscovy ducks and most awesome late is
Lincoln who pretty much just danced
around me letting me take awesome
pictures of it even though they're one
of the most rare species of birds in
Florida and almost went extinct in the
early 1900's I made another interesting
discovery while here in Florida while
visiting my old college I stopped by my
old 7-eleven then I found a beverage
that you might be interested in
Katherine and I are still on the early
tour of the entire southeastern United
States and I'm gonna look in at liquor
stores wherever I go
trying to find Boone's Farm Strawberry
Hill flavored citrus wine met 7-eleven
next my old college and I have found
Strawberry Hill I'm about to buy it so
that I can complete the Strawberry Hill
challenge finally it looks really gross
and it costs it doesn't say how much it
costs but I only have five minutes up to
buy it five minutes to spare that's kind
of exciting
you guys saying there's like feminism to
my beer yeah hurry a better very soon
because you can't sell alcohol on
Sundays in the state of Florida simcha
buy this right now we're all - not going
to get it by but you're gonna have to
wait until Wednesday to see the
completion of the Strawberry Hill
challenge because I don't have time to
edit it here in this airport so far
you'll see me on Wednesday drinking
Strawberry Hill and I'll see you
tomorrow